- Well, speaking of the outdoors,
your husband is obsessed
with just animals.
- Yes.
- How many do you have?
You don't like animals.
(laughs)
- No, I love, I love animals.
But he has reptiles.
So, he has like 45 to 50
reptiles that live underneath us.
No snakes, that was the deal.
I said no snakes,
but so, when we actually dated
a little over a decade ago,
I knew that I was marrying
a guy who loves reptiles.
You know what I mean?
So, it was fine.
I said as so long as--
- That's a lot, that's 40 to 50?
- Yeah.
- Wow.
- Iguanas is like, that
looked like alligators.
- Do you have a dog?
- Yes, A little Frenchie.
She's my little baby.
So I'm like stay far away.
Yes, so she's an indoorsy type dog.
Likes to go on walks, but
stays away from the cages.
- Okay okay, stays from the cages
sounds like a great place.
(laughs)
Your partner on Dancing
with the Stars last season
was Cody Rigsby, he was here last year.
So what was he like as a partner?
- Oh, he's amazing.
I mean, he's so inspirational.
- So joyful.
- He's so joyful, but
he's also a hard worker,
like he worked seven days a week.
He wanted to get the routines right.
And it didn't come easy.
And I just saw so many
different sides to Cody.
Like he is this like bubbly person,
but he also has a real
human side to him too,
which was refreshing for sure.